and say
come listen say
we got Cody's Cafe here where the [__]
where's Noelle
what the hell
I put in all this effort into my own
cart here and he's not even he doesn't
even show up for it we got Cody's eats
here
the ultimate space Diner
looks like I just have beer
I just offer Miller Lite
perverted family special what the hell
was that
okay I gotta admit I outsourced the menu
so I don't really know what's on here
but perverted family special is first
what is that
what the [__] is happening now
whoops
sorry
sorry I uh
[Music]
sorry
what the [__] is this oh
oh my bad
oh my bad dude I
oh I started a new business I uh no I
started a new business
oh [__] no I got uh the bike it
physically was like taxing sites
[__] man I'm sorry
where did you even get this straight
from Italy man I I got a ton back here
man the storage is awesome
oh
I'm pissed I'm pissed off you know the
little love you go through what is a
little lobster juice we have lobster
juice Mad Dog 40 40 but it's
called Lobster juice
um
awesome oh look
I'm even sponsored by arawan
um
sorry dude
smells good in here right yeah it smells
awesome
love another carbon monoxide episode
perfect
what the [__] do I have perverted family
special
let's see let's see what you got dude
um
in beer we try you don't even serve beer
dude oh wait you do I do yeah
okay none of this [__] is working
you know the lengths I had to go through
to get this
to set up this business I spun up a
whole LLC I'm sorry man I and you gotta
show me up with this [__] thing what
even is this it's a Piaggio ope 50. of
course of course it is well it's
catalyzed too
it helps on the smell
well can I get a latte yeah yeah let's
do it yeah
you know after last week's I was
lightheaded for like three hours
afterwards yeah well and it's gonna be
another one of those yep I mean driving
home just faded as hell yes off the
exhaust
yeah yeah and it's it stinks again yeah
as it smells good I can't believe that
you did this if they had a cologne of
this I'd wear it go-karts
is cosplaying I mean that's what I'm
gonna sell man I'm gonna sell a male uh
cosplaying kit yeah where it's got
a go-kart stench and a little it's a
little tub of like some black dye you
can dip your fingertips in there and rub
it on your hands to make it look like
you've been working on cars all day yeah
yeah what about like candles that smell
like power tools and [__] like that um
yeah that would be sick actually that's
not a bad idea for like a joke company
yeah thanks
that's pretty good and then you do like
makeup tutorials where you're like
getting your hands dirty imagine if
what are you doing it no no no
unless unless unless you never know I
mean guy like me oh they already [__]
did it this hardware store that's funny
see we should invent this
do you want do you want to invent that
so you can finally know what it's like
to go outside of your house
I want to know what it's like to be a
real man that ugh it does this [__] you
know in the form of a candle it goes to
Home Depot and isn't scared of it
[Laughter]
oh by the way we're on a brand new
planet today yeah looks good speaking of
leaving home yeah uh we actually landed
on planet
um
that's what I meant yeah [__] and ball
four yeah and uh it's beautiful electric
I would say yeah
no just kidding we're at Outside Lands
yeah we're both launched rooms right
yeah
we just dropped in the middle of uh
Outside Lands
yeah and that that's just um
that's uh whatever the coolest DJ is
right now that's just his video wall
back there no way
[Laughter]
who are you pumped to see
[Music]
DJ kalis yes
DJ Khaled yeah call me asparagus
have you watched any like compilations
of him yeah it's so funny the one that
killed me recently homius Burgers what
the roses are red one
someone edited it so there's no
punchline wait what does he say he's
like roses are red
violets are blue and it just then it
just shows them like walking in a circle
and he never
completes it
the best one is him going and this is
called what and this is called what and
this is cool and she's like and that's
like bacon eggs
and and perhaps what is this called and
perhaps what is this that's water
it's so good he's asking his Chef like
what the [__] on his plate is yeah
he's so funny wouldn't it be awesome if
one day he just Andy Kaufman does all
like
oh I just coffee come to myself
yep just like that
oh man you didn't watch that video I
sent you did you I waited I'm gonna wait
okay okay did you click on it you see
the thumbnail or anything I waited to
watch it because uh everyone's like you
guys don't make videos together anymore
so
that's how they sound in the comments
you know I'll never make videos anymore
that's what we do all the time yeah so I
waited to watch it with you okay but
we're gonna have to
like for a video or you want to watch on
here we're gonna watch it on here yeah
yeah okay we might have to do it in the
bonus if we do it on the main we're
gonna have to censor it and we might it
might get us age restricted but it's for
those of you that are wondering it's
that lady
with her uh big old ass big old derriere
in the air and her Mega Man boots on
those designer Astro Boy boots and she's
so you did watch it I just watched the
first three seconds okay okay she's
[__] doing a captain Falcon kick into
that guy's balls and it is so good yeah
and I went to her profile
I dug through the thing found her
profile clicked that you clicked the
Google just because I was doing more
research videos to find right and I
there's more of her she had like a
session that was like a dominatrix
session right so then you went to her
Googling and her profile the Google form
you filled it out you're like yeah
availability yeah on Monday Thursday
yeah Saturday exactly yeah well first I
went to her only fans signed up yeah
highest tier okay Flex okay
[Laughter]
yeah just showing you my favorite only
fans creator of the week uh signed up to
uh um uh I don't [__] know Eva Star 7
uh highest oh she's great
highest tier highest tier yeah I think
it's a great thing to jack off to